petrushka fabulous says the coronavirus
has been good for his business
especially in the run-up to Easter
people are stocking up on food because
they're afraid of shortages but they're
also sitting at home watching cooking
shows and experimenting with new recipes
Kufa Poulos is one of the businesses
considered essential by the government
that didn't have to close due to
coronavirus customers have to keep their
distance one per 15 square meters but
for other firms it's a different story
the lockdown measures were announced on
Friday night I was about to pay my rent
on Saturday morning and called my
landlord to say I'm not going to pay you
this month and a good thing too because
I've been living off that rent for the
past month Greece is spending fifteen
billion dollars supporting affected
businesses and workers until June it's
lockdown began early carnival
celebrations were cancelled in February
schools were closed on March 10th a week
before France in Germany and ten days
before the UK people who don't live on
the islands aren't allowed to sail there
so ferries a traveling light mainly to
keep trade alive all this has led to
Greece having a fatality rate of 9 per
million much lower than the death rates
in most European countries sources close
to the prime minister say the government
knew the national health system couldn't
cope with a major outbreak early
measures would create a recession but so
would a health crisis so the government
opted to trigger an early recession
calculating that this would save lives
and give it a stronger economic recovery
but some say there was another goal
stemming from Greece's decade-long
economic crisis a competent government
that can respond efficiently to these
unexpected events and if we do so we
believe that people will turn around and
say you know what Greece is a serious
country and maybe we will get over this
image that people had from the
experiences that they had the previous
decade we hope that this in itself will
be able to attract investments in the
future the International Monetary Fund
predicts a 10 percent recession for
Greece this year followed by five
percent growth next year if that
assessment is correct coronavirus could
mark a turning point giving Greece the
economic recovery many here want after a
decade of economic crisis jumps our
applause al Jazeera Athens